[Musica]
grazie buonasera a tutti e si la storia
per me è davvero una passione una
passione particolare che si concentra
soprattutto nel nostro territorio perché
amo la storia locale amo soprattutto la
storia orale e il recupero delle delle
biografie femminili la storia da
insegnante la reputo e in generale da
cittadina la reputo un uno strumento
importante per la formazione della
persona perché possa essere da adulto un
interprete della cittadinanza attiva e
quindi se la storia importante e giusto
che il racconto della storia sia
completo purtroppo la storiografia fino
adesso non ha dato conto di una gran
parte del protagonismo della nostra
storia diciamo che il passato è
rappresentato come se fosse stato
realizzato soltanto da una parte di
umanità che è quella maschile che è
quella che ha governato la scrittura
della storia e quindi scritta dagli
uomini e per gli uomini e in generale
per gli uomini importanti ha ovviamente
trascurato una parte importante di
soggetti che ne hanno fatto la
differenza e quindi il recupero della
storia femminile della storia delle
donne anche significato in qualche modo
il recupero di una parte di protagonismo
della storia che può essere riferito
alle persone comuni anche ai tanti
uomini non importanti che pure hanno
dato il loro contributo che gli eventi
si dipanasse rowe nel modo che noi
conosciamo quindi direi che che
l'impegno di parlare di recuperare di
scoprire quello che le donne hanno fatto
è importante proprio per dar conto di
come sono andate le cose e di quello che
le donne sono riuscite a fare grazie
alla loro tenacia alle loro competenze
alla loro volitività e diciamo che da
che le storiche italiane hanno avviato
questo percorso è cambiata un po la
prospettiva e direi che possiamo dire
che essere riconosciute per quello che
s'è fatto è stato sicuramente
importantissimo e ha fatto in modo che
si potessero in qualche modo definire
momenti della storia che in passato
erano stati guardati e studiati senza
tener conto di alcune parti importanti
allora inizierei subito dal fatto che
per esempio il l'utilizzo dei termini
l'utilizzo dell'astico ha condizionato
moltissimo anche la interpretazione di
quello che è accaduto di quello che
leggiamo sui manuali di storia
pensiamo all'utilizzo della parola uomo
che viene indifferentemente utilizzato
per indicare l'uomo uomini e donne
oppure pensiamo al termine universale
per universale si intende tutto ma in
verità la maggior parte delle volte nei
libri di storia leggiamo universale per
intendere soltanto la parte maschile
un momento importante nel recupero di
questa di una visione giusta del
racconto della storia è stato
sicuramente il 150º dell'università
dell'unità d'italia perché in quella
circostanza c'è stata una produzione
importante di ricerche che hanno portato
fuori profili di donne di levatura
intellettuale altissima ma anche donne
semplici che hanno dato un apporto
irrinunciabile
l'affermazione degli ideali liberali
degli ideali risorgimentali pannella
nell'idea nostra del risorgimento
pensiamo ai valorosi che hanno fatto
tutte le le imprese che sappiamo se
parliamo di donne pensiamo alla contessa
di castiglione quindi abbiamo un'idea di
green all in ed i salotti invece
assolutamente no son venute fuori storie
di tantissime donne che hanno fatto la
differenza donne che hanno sì ha avuto
hanno gestito dei salotti ma dai quali
si disseminavano e divulgavano gli
ideali importanti e la forza il coraggio
per fare delle imprese anche anche delle
battaglie partecipare ad eventi che
hanno cambiato il corso della storia e
quindi abbiamo delle combattenti abbiamo
delle banchiere le infermiere
addirittura una cannoniera che ha
risolto una battaglia in sicilia le
donne insomma hanno dato tanto senza
trascurare peraltro quella parte
importante della nostra vita che è
l'amore materno o l'amore per il
valoroso compagno che sicuramente è
stato valoroso riconoscere la storia
come fatta anche dalle donne non vuol
dire diminuire quello che è stato fatto
dagli uomini vuol dire dare la
completezza della visione di quello che
è stato è appunto se la storia è uno
strumento deve essere raccontata nel
modo giusto pensiamo alla rivoluzione
francese
allora si dice che l'uomo che gli uomini
nascono e restano liberi e uguali nei
diritti cioè un affermazione che ci dà
il senso della conquista della libertà
in realtà nel 1793 quindi proprio nel
pieno della rivoluzione robespierre
ghigliottina o lamp deluso che è un
icona dell'emancipazione femminile era
stata costretta a scrivere la
dichiarazione dei diritti della donna e
della cittadina perché la dichiarazione
dei diritti dell'uomo e del cittadino in
realtà
rispondeva a quel senso di universalità
e invece dovrebbe connotare la
l'acquisizione l'esercizio dei diritti
se questi sono davvero universali e a
questo proposito credo che sia
importante pensare che la cancellazione
delle donne quindi la conquista di una
riconoscibilità nelle cose che hanno
fatto è che fanno passa sicuramente per
la conquista dei diritti civili e dei
diritti politici ma se pensiamo che nel
1906 25 luglio per la precisione venne
emessa una sentenza storica proprio
dalla corte di appello di ancona da un
giurista che sarà poi importante per la
storia del nostro paese che si chiamava
ludovico mortara sotto l'impulso e la
sollecitazione di donne abbastanza
straordinarie tra le quali maria
montessori 10 maestre anconetane e fiero
di essere iscritte nelle liste
elettorali della provincia di ancona
il giudice mortara era totalmente
contrario a che le donne votassero
perché credeva che le donne non fossero
in grado di poterlo fare
ciò nonostante il suo rigore di giurista
gli permise di leggere nell'articolo 24
del dl dello statuto albertino
effettivamente che non c'erano
impedimenti a espliciti anche le donne
potessero esercitare diritto di voto
nella fattispecie erano delle su di te
che avevano che erano alfabeti e avevano
anche un reddito quindi ci stava questa
sentenza scombinò completamente le
questioni in tutta italia per cui il
grande movimento di reazione che sia
ebbe portò nel maggio dell'anno
successivo all'annullamento di quella di
quella storica sentenza per cui le donne
marchigiane le donne italiane dovettero
aspettare 40 anni per arrivare
all'esercizio del diritto di voto perché
badate bene il suffragio universale in
italia è del 1946 non è certo del 1916
come si legge su
di storia perché quello era suffragio
maschile universale non è maschile
universale a e maschile e femminile
un'altra prova di di illusione di
raggiungere la istituzionalizzazione di
un ruolo importante nella vita pubblica
del nostro paese
lo leggiamo lo vediamo nel durante il
regime fascista
la donna doveva era importante perché
aveva un ruolo importante ma qual era
era quello di essere procreatrice la
fattrice che doveva creato far nascere
procreare e allevare i soldati per la
nostra patria perché bisognava
conquistare e colonizzare il mondo
chi non si conforma va a quel modello
scandito dalle regole del regime era in
qualche modo emarginata o comunque
perseguitata se non addirittura
neutralizzata con il manicomio
moltissime sale sono le donne chiusa in
manicomio durante il regime
eppure proprio durante quel ventennio
che le donne italiane danno una grande
prova di se stesse e elaborando un forte
spirito antifascista e poi partecipando
anche alla resistenza in modo
sicuramente determinante è molto più di
quanto poi la storia ci abbia raccontato
negli anni successivi e dunque che dirvi
per me è veramente entusiasmante quando
vado a ricercare tra gli archivi oppure
nei racconti ancora nei racconti delle
persone le notizie e quanto possa essere
utile per ricostruire il profilo di il
profilo di alcune donne tengo
particolarmente alle donne marchigiane
perché ne abbiamo esempi davvero
straordinari
e sebbene noi siamo considerati una
regione marginale di fatto abbiamo dato
la nostra il nostro apporto sostanziale
allo sviluppo del nostro paese
tanto per dirvi qualche figura oltre
alla montessori maria montessori che è
stata una pedagogista riconosciuta a
livello internazionale per ben tre volte
candidata al premio nobel per la pace
perché è stata una grande difensore dei
diritti dei diritti civili e dei diritti
personali e per esempio adele bei che è
stata lei di estrazione molto semplice
era di famiglia operaia e lei stessa era
un'operaia durante il fascismo fu
perseguitata per le sue idee contrarie
al regime fece anche il carcere duro
perché il tribunale speciale ne sancì
paurosamente sulla sua reclusione è
stata una delle madri costituenti
devo assolutamente parlarvi di due donne
straordinarie della nostra città che
sono franca maria matricardi che in
quello stesso periodo si laurea in
ingegneria è diventata negli anni
sessanta una manager della editoria
italiana e milanese straordinaria
durante gli anni del liceo fu nuotatrice
della squadra di terra di nazionale
italiana sciatrice scalatrice pensate
che vince una borsa di studio negli
stati uniti e prima di andare nel 39 in
america aveva già volato in europa e
aveva preso lezioni di voto dai di volo
da italo balbo lei apparteneva a una
famiglia molto molto agiata e
protagonista della vita della nostra
città ma c'è un'altra donna che vive
ancora e che ancora in grado di darci
un'energia incredibile nelle cose che fa
e dai gd a coccia lei invece una donna
molto semplice che durante la resistenza
le uccisero il promesso sposo e si aderì
alla lotta armata e diventò la postina
perché conosceva molto bene l'alfabeto
morse e quindi portare una porta ordini
che comunicava le notizie fondamentali
la banda blick che si trovava nei boschi
tra castignano in rotella la notte
portava degli zaini che arrivavano a
pesare anche 20 kg pieni di fucili di
armi e di munizioni
la sua storia è stata una storia di
dolori di difficoltà ma anche di grandi
gioie vissute all'interno anche di
quelle esperienze così impegnative
ancora oggi quando viene a scuola
approccia con i ragazzi facendogli
questa domanda voi quanto il padre di
scarpe avete perché lei in realtà non
aveva le scarpe aveva solo degli zoccoli
scavati nel legno coperti da una pelle
di coniglio che si strappavano con
niente con l'acqua con un urto eppure
nonostante i piedi scalzi le sfide della
vita le ha vissute tutte da vittoriosa e
continua ancora oggi lei è nata nel 24
continua ancora oggi ad avere un'idea
propositiva del futuro ea contaminare
quell'energia fondamentale che serve
davvero per andare avanti e poi che
dirvi per esempio delle delle tante
vergare che nella nostra regione con la
loro sapienza e con i loro mestieri
hanno in qualche modo traghettato il
nostro l'economia della nostra regione
verso l'industrializzazione perché
quella loro sapienza e poi diventata in
forme più elaborate la micro
imprenditorialità che è un modello anche
al di fuori della nostra regione
e poi che dirvi per esempio delle balie
di ripatransone che tra la fine
dell'ottocento e l'inizio del novecento
da sole andarono in egitto per svolgere
il loro lavoro di bali e presso le
famiglie europei che la si erano
trasferite per i lavori della iii del
canale di suez le quali ovviamente hanno
sfidato le convenzioni hanno superato
paure hanno lasciato i loro affetti ma
per portare per restituire benessere
alla loro discendenza e allo stesso
tempo degli stili progrediti di vita dai
quali non si è tornati indietro
e quindi che dirvi parlare di storie
delle donne ovviamente avete visto che
mi infervora molto mi entusiasma molto
però penso che sia necessario sia
necessario parlarne alle donne e agli
uomini soprattutto per evitare alle
donne e l'auto e l'auto
marginalizzazione e agli uomini per far
capire per darvi l'opportunità di
conoscere come la dignità delle donne
sia esattamente pari a quella degli
uomini
e in questo modo sconfiggere quegli
stereotipi che ci rovinano la vita che
spesso producono comportamenti di
sopraffazione di predominio e spesso di
violenza delle quali purtroppo noi di
quella violenza sappiamo quanto quanto
sia brutto è che brutto peso abbia la
nostra società
vi ringrazio sono riusciti a non
sconfinare tralasciato sicuramente tante
donne importanti grazie
[Applauso]